guillaume lassalle au mali comme le veut
sa vie comme behren zizanie chez les
verts donc bien évidemment ne comprenait
pas ce que je disais parce que je parle
une autre donc parce qu'il ya quinze ans
j'ai fait l'effort d'apprendre notre
langue mais à 15 ans millions à 15 ans
je savais exactement ce que j'avais fait
docteur en pharmacie
c'est vraiment quelque chose que je
ressentais que toute façon que j'allais
faire ça je devais être docteur en
pharmacie
c'est le rêve pour ma mère mais c'était
pas mon rêve mais est ce qu'on connaît
vraiment notre rêve est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous vous vous tous vous
connaissez vraiment le rêve de votre vie
en fait on connaît pas notre notre rêve
tant que l'appât rencontre est vraiment
et -19 ans j'ai rencontré le rêve de ma
vie en fait j'ai rencontré l'homme de ma
vie et par conséquence j'ai brisé le
rêve de ma mère ou en fait à 19 ans je
peux pas j'ai pas pu aller voir ma mère
parce que c'est trop compliqué je
voulais voir mon père et mon père
j'avais vu dire papa je me marie un oui
oui je me marie j'ai rencontré à deux
heures c'est l'homme de ma vie c'est un
peu la réaction en fait oui bien sûr mon
rêve c'est l'homme de ma vie est là non
mais il avait ni mes origines et la ve
lu ma langue est parlée le ni ma langue
on n'avait pas la même culture oui papa
c'est un français c'était vraiment c'est
ce que je voulais faire c'était
absolument le rêve de ma vie je le
rencontrais je peux pas l'expliquer papa
c'était oui je parle pas français
sûrement je parle pas français mais
c'était dans le regard papa de soissons
je peux pas te l'expliquer c'est je peux
me marier et ça sera lui mais en fait on
parle pas la même langue
2 enfin en fait ils ont raison du bas
dans deux mois cette façon s'est
terminée ce truc là ils sont bien sympas
mais mais ce fut le seul vraiment le le
premier saut de ma vie en fait c'est de
sauter parce que j'ai aimé quelqu'un a
un coup de foudre
mais je pars linus et la langue on
n'avait pas les mêmes origines moi je te
suis marocaine vie c'est un français je
parlais pas français
et en plus de ça je connaissais rien en
france mais vraiment on est d'une
famille pauvre et du coup on n'avait pas
cette on n'avait pas beaucoup internet
moi je suis pas très loin non plus on
n'avait pas trop à internet dans du coup
on n'avait pas cette
internationalisation qui est aujourd'hui
mais j'ai dit à mon père avec ici qu'est
ce qui va pas la langue je vais
apprendre la culture en scène donc on va
apprendre notre notre culture l'un et
l'autre
oui la distance mais je vais vous parler
au téléphone je vais venir tout le temps
mais en fait ce que j'ai envie de vous
dire avec ça avec le avec le pas que
j'ai ce saut que j'ai fait vraiment
inconscient au moins une copine qui
vient me voir aujourd'hui il me dit ben
j'ai rencontré aujourd'hui c'est l'homme
de ma vie je vais aller aux états unis
vivre avec lui je lui dire mais tu es
folle ou quoi bien sûr mais j'ai envie
de vous dire en fait ces obstacles a en
fait la langue la distance vivre loin de
sa famille mais en fait on en fait il
faut en faire des leviers en fait pour
grandir bâle a donc gelé a pris
heureusement aujourd'hui je veux pas
peut-être avec des faux seins je suis
désolé mais je commence à vraiment j'ai
appris la langue
j'ai vécu avec mon mari pendant un an et
demi au maroc donc du coup il a pris ma
culture et bah du coup c'est très bien
ma mère qui était vraiment un peu triste
parce que je n'ai pas réalisé son rêve
sediba bon elle a fait peut-être le bon
choix maintenant elle est mariée elle va
elle va elle va maintenant j'ai une
fille mariée montréal maintenant c'est
de voir ses petits enfants quoi et en
fait c'est là où je dis nos rêves on les
connaît pas tant qu'on les a pas
rencontrés en fait après deux ans
j'étais femme au foyer
chouchoutez un homme aimant j'avais tout
en fait j'étais dans un confort de vie
exceptionnelle tout allait bien mais
qu'est ce qui va paraît déjà en fait je
romps se trompent pas et cette fois ci
vers des études j'étais très bien avec
mon mari
j'étais en france mais j'ai rencontré
l'amour d'indépendance en fait je
voulais être indépendantes
financièrement indépendantes socialement
j'avais moment réalisé en tant que
l'individu est pas tant que fille ou en
tant que femme au foyer
ben en fait quand j'ai repris mes études
je parlais la langue à peu près mais
j'écrivais pas parce qu au maroc où j'ai
appris tout mes études étaient en arabe
tout le monde l'a dit mr à dire qu'est
ce que tu veux tout allait bien pourquoi
tu pourquoi tu grossis chef du problème
en fait toi ça avait bien fait dans un
enfant tu vas bien qu'est ce que tu as à
faire apprendre des études tu as des
sites ont barré tout seul à la maison ça
fait deux ans va et bah qu'est ce qu'il
va en fait la peur de risque était été
moins fort que c'est envie et ce désir
de tout gagner en fait donc genre sauter
le pas vers les études c'était le
meilleur choix de ma vie en fait
sincèrement je le reconnais aujourd'hui
si je n'avais pas pris mes études je
serais pas là aujourd'hui à vous parler
tout simplement j'ai construit ma
carrière est encore une fois vous allez
des obstacles vous parlais pas français
je parlais la france tout je parlais pas
français je j'ai fait des études en
arabe donc d'aller refaire sur mes
études en français et je me suis dit
c'est pas grave j'apprends donc j'ai
travaillé un peu plus que les autres
donc je travaille le samedi le dimanche
le soir j'apprenais par corps l'économie
parc hors le droit
donc j'ai j'ai tout appris par coeur
parce que parfois je comprenais pas ce
que je lisais j'étais première de ma
classe la première année la deuxième
année de bts
c'était les deux années où j'ai plus
travaillé de ma vie un bts ou le valais
on va passer à un examen sur deux ans
franchement j'avais le boule au ventre
ce super j'ai réussi mes études parce
que j'ai travaillé donc bien évidemment
c'est jorro commence ça c'est le
deuxième saut de ma vie je vais vous
parler après deux troisièmes ce même si
des obstacles y en a mais c'est pas
grave fait de ces obstacles devraient
levier pour apprendre et pour réaliser
votre rêve en fait ce que j'ai envie de
vous dire aussi ce qu'il n'y a pas un
seul saut y a pas un seul j'ai sauté le
pas une fois et s'est terminée non
j'espère que vous avez vous avez je
pense qu'en 20 ans 21 ans 22 ans ou max
max mais dans 30 ans vous allez changer
vous allez avoir d'autres trêve parce
que votre est vous l'avez pas encore
rencontré tout simplement
donc moi j'ai après mes études soient
des jusqu'au master j'ai intégré une
super grande boîte de yaourt je pense
qu'on a pas mal qui connaissent ici
le leader du marché des yaourts en
france et dans le monde paye et j'étais
très bien c'est un rêve d'intégrer une
super bonne boîte de yaourt
ma mère elle était contente
ah ouais j'y arrive pas pas su pas super
vite mais oh
elle a fait des études maintenant elle
est cadre super ça fait trois ans
qu'elle est dans ce superbe boîte d
amour tu es là et je vais vous parler de
leur troisième pas troisième son
troisième saut c'est aussi dû à une
rencontre moi je pensais que mon rêve
était chez danone et je commençais à
préparer ma carrière après j'ai passé
six ans dans ce superbe bonne boîte du
yaourt troisième pas c'est quand j'ai
rencontré une dame qui s'appelle pascal
et qui avait un cancer de sein les
récidives sont son deuxième concert de
ça et je me suis dit je vais l'aider
mais je vais l'aider du man
art plus concrète pas longtemps que
bénévole en tant que bénévole moi mais
je vais le faire autant en tant que
entrepreneurs de ma boîte
donc j'ai proposé un projet à cette
bonne boîte du yaourt et genre proposé
de faire un projet avec la ligue contre
le cancer
on a fait un super opération qui elle
est généralisée ou nationale 2 2 avec
cette ligue là les contrats concernent
en fait c'était super parce que j'avais
fait un super course dans cette belle
boîte de et je me suis fait remarquer ma
carrière a commencé tout tracé mais en
fait ce superbe opération que j'ai fait
pour ma carrière professionnelle
c'était le déclic en fait les boutiques
parce que j'ai rencontré un autre un mot
troisième moment de ma vie l'amour
d'entreprendre
en fait quand j'ai fait ce projet je ne
pouvais plus retourner un moment à cette
veine mois de juillet août et à être
dans une carrière toute tracée
en fait j'ai compris que je suis un peu
hybride et j'avais envie de
d'entreprendre mais avec un pacte parce
qu'aujourd'hui entreprendre c'est bien
mais entreprendre avec un pacte c'est
mieux et donc du coup je suis allé j'ai
appelé ma mère je lui dis bah en fait ça
fait six ans que je porte un lob du coup
bah je vais partir et je vais
entreprendre pour dans quoi bah en fait
dans la restauration
est-ce que jamais rentré dans un
restaurant j'ai jamais cuisiné
mais par contre je suis tombée amoureuse
de ces faits la pelle et du coup je me
suis dit je vais en faire des boulettes
de pois chiches qui rassemble je vais
faire les falafels préféré des français
mais je vais le faire avec du sens et du
coup bah je vais pas rentrer je veux pas
faire de la pub sur on n'est pas là pour
ça mais j'ai envie de vous dire quelque
chose aussi ce qu'ont voulu entreprendre
c'est comme j'ai fait croix sur mes
études croire sur mon expérience
professionnelle et je redémarre ix20
ordonnait à 12,0 parce que j'ai appris à
cuisiner des falafels j'ai appris à
manager des personnes qui sont loin de
l'emploi parce que je fais pas de griffe
à l'appel tout seul je le fais avec une
équipe formidable c'est des personnes
réfugiées qu'il faut enlever falafel
avec moi donc du coup j'ai appris à
parler à entreprendre avec des personnes
qu'ils ont besoin d'un job qu'ils ont
besoin d'accompagnement qu'ils ont
besoin de d'être accompagné et c'est ça
en fait j'ai envie de vous dire que
votre rêve voulons vous allez rencontrer
aujourd'hui demain après-demain dans le
dix ans dans 15 ans n'hésitez pas en
fait en faire un vrai levier n'hésitait
pas à faire de votre expérience et de
mêmes ces obstacles en faire un vrai
levier pour aller plus loin et est
aujourd'hui en fait encore plus avec la
crise avec la crise
le coc vide c'est vraiment une très
belle opportunité pour vous parce que le
champ est ouvert en fait même s'ils ont
des crs qu'il faut pas il faut pas il
faut pas investir il faut pas
entreprendre il faut pas essayer mais
non c'est maintenant en fait tout est
ouvert tout est possible vous savez une
idée vous savez pas faire du neuf
vous avez pas faire savait pas coder
c'est pas grave aujourd'hui il ya des
outils nos codes pour vous former
rapidement sur sur comment lancer un
projet rapidement
donc en fait ce que j'ai envie de vous
dire de vraiment de au fond de moi même
c'est n'hésitez pas à aller à aller vers
cet inconnu pour réaliser votre rêve
n'hésitez pas à aller chaque obstacle
identifier ces obstacles et fait un plan
tout simplement rien n'est impossible
rien n'est impossible tout tout pousse à
prendre tu peux tu peux être réalisable
il faut juste faire un plan l'identifier
être travailleur ça sert à ça je pense
que je vais pas réinventer la roue mais
est travailleur être endurant et
déterminée et aujourd'hui je le vis avec
ma ma boîte c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans l'événementiel aussi c'est un peu
compliqué pour nous mais on en train de
pivoter on en train d'essayer d'autres
choses et on est convaincu que ça va
marcher
on est convaincus on change le produit
en changeant la cible on recommence tout
à zéro ça va marcher mais c'est juste
que aujourd'hui vous avez à vous êtes
dans une bonne dans un très bon
écosystèmes faites votre réseau essayez
réaliser tout ce qu'on vous a envie
d'apprendre
mais il ne restait pas n'évite pas
n'existe pas ok je vais pas y arriver
ou c'est trop dur pour moi autre façon
j'ai pas la capacité ou j'ai pas le bon
réseau ça c'est vraiment c'est du
bullshit
comment du cdu c'est que du seco d
autocensure c'est le plafond de verre
qu'on n'a pas envie de qu'on n'a pas
envie de casser parce qu'on a peur
d'échouer mais c'est pas grave si on
échoue il recommence donc c'est ce que
j'ai envie de vous dire je ne sais pas
si j'ai répondu à votre question
guillaume merci beaucoup et à très
bientôt
[Applaudissements]